There are a lot of
visualizations in the world
and we don't have
time for them all.
So let's focus on one
particularly abused plot
type, the pie chart.
We have a specimen right here.
This is a pie chart of
phone application crashes,
showing what percentage
of all crashes
took place in each
mobile operating system.
This data set
contains information
for all versions of Apple's iOS,
which is used in the iPhone,
as well as the various
versions of Google's Android.
There are many things
wrong with this plot,
but let's break
down exactly what.
Putting aside, for a moment,
that there are far too
many labels, check out
the ordering of the labels
corresponding to iOS.
Two sensible ways
of ordering iOS data
might be by
decreasing percentage
or by version number.
Instead, we start at the
top with iOS 3.13, with 0%,
and then jump to iOS
4.2.10, with 12.64%,
before going back down to
iOS 3.2, with 0.00% again.
Which brings us to
the number of labels.
Many of the segments
are so narrow that they
can't be seen, although
technically, all data is
retained, because every
segment is labeled.
If we look at iOS,
we see that there
are only three major versions,
3, 4, and 5, suggesting
we can compress down the
iOS segments to just three
segments, while retaining
most of the information.
At the least, the versions
that differ in the third number
should be combined, and all data
points of 0% should be removed.
The more fundamental concern
of this visualization
is that it might
really be showing
the percentage of
the phone market
using each operating system, and
says nothing about whether one
operating system crashes
more than the other, which
is the focus of
this visualization.
Our next pie chart has
its own share of problems.
This is a plot of how
many shark attacks have
been attributed to
each type of shark.
Firstly, the pie chart
is, for some reason,
plotted on a hemisphere,
a graphical effect that
adds nothing, but has the
effect of vertically compressing
the pie chart.
Next, there is the issue
of label orientation.
While the caption, "Shark
species (total/deaths)",
and the label, "White
shark", are horizontal,
the rest are vertical
and hard to read.
They are in order,
however, which does help.
Although the "Others" segment
is unfortunately large,
which is unclear if it is due
to there being a lot of attacks
by many species, or
if the species is not
known for many attacks.
Finally, at a glance, it
is hard to distinguish
the magnitude of differences
between the orange, green,
blue, and brown segments in
the top part of the pie chart,
and we must resort to the labels
to distinguish between them.
There is no meaning in the
colors, they are arbitrary.
Finally, we'll look
at a pie chart I made,
of the origins of the
international students at MIT.
I made this chart with
the default settings
in Google Sheets.
First of all, not
all of the segments
are labeled, so
that data is lost,
for the Middle East,
Africa, Oceania,
and the unknown regions.
Second, again, we have colors
that are arbitrary and almost
close enough to be confusing.
The difference between Asia
and Africa's colors is subtle.
And of course, the
3D-effect on the pie
chart adds nothing, but does
play a subtle trick on the eye.
Due to the 3D-effect,
the blue and red segments
are actually larger
looking, which at a glance,
may lead the viewer to
overestimate their size.
What we are going to do
now is, switch over to R
and plot this data more
appropriately, using ggplot.
And then we'll
return to the slides,
to discuss some more
possibilities for this data.